book dot com slash book tv
or you can send an email to book tv at
cspan.org what's on your summer reading
list book tv wants to know
eric bogosian recounts a group of
armenian patriots who in 1921 set out to
assassinate former turkish leaders to
avenge the victims of the 1915 armenian
genocide
they ended up killing six former leaders
in four european cities and then
disbanded and disappeared forever
ladies and gentlemen
it is a pleasure to welcome eric
bogosian to our stage this evening arab
yoshin is an actor playwright novelist
he attended the university of chicago
for graduating from oberlin he is an
author and actor known for his plays
talk radio and suburbia in recent years
he has started on broadway and time
stands still and was featured in law and
order criminal tennis captain danny ross
he has published three novels titled
maul wasted beauty and perforated heart
air bogosian is a guggenheim fellow in
the recipient of two fellowships from
the national endowment of the arts
we are here tonight to celebrate the
release of his newest book titled
operation nemesis the assassination plot
that avenged the armenian genocide
without any further ado
please welcome aeropoganzian
[Applause]
thank you thanks for showing up and on
this beautiful
late afternoon
i will read a little bit from the book
and then i will
say a few things i might say them while
i'm reading the book i never know what
i'm doing exactly
and then we'll do a few questions which
i'm actually
i actually like questions i like
answering questions
when i was a little kid
there was nothing i loved better than
hanging out at my grandparents house
in her sunny kitchen my grandma lucy
would fashion honey-drenched armenian
pastries while out in the backyard
grandpa miguel ditch roasted lamb shish
kebab under the apple trees
after dessert grandpa might knock back a
tiny glass of arak and tell me stories
i was held wrapped by the horrific
narratives he dredged up from his far
away past
in his sweetly accented english
migration would describe burning
churches and sadistic horsemen
the stories would always end the same
way
my grandfather would instruct me
if you ever meet a turk
kill him
i was no more than four years old when i
first heard those words
yeah so four-year-old little eric
learning about the bad stuff that
happened over there
my grandfather was a refugee from that
um
those hard harsh times and the violence
and he miraculously escaped with his
life
he was about 20 years old
i'm not going to make this into a
lecture about what the book is about
tonight because the there's just too
much in here in fact when i was getting
ready to
put this little reading together tonight
i realized one of the reasons why i
liked doing this project so much
made out of
dozens of little pieces that all fit
together into a bigger hole and i like
working with lots of pieces to make a
bigger hole it it's it appeals to me
it's the way i put used to put my solo
shows together and i feel that when you
can put something together that way you
can
you're like guarding me is that what
you're doing
just having somebody behind me all the
time is a little
we're good
um
you know of course this book ends up
coming out this week as we celebrate the
100 years
since the armenian genocide uh began it
actually began
uh we we used the date april 24th to
signify the beginning of the armenian
genocide because on april 24th hundreds
of armenian
uh intellectuals and jurists and um
doctors lawyers all were arrested in in
constantinople
and
now you're upstaging me dudes you gotta
chill sit down
um
and so
oh this is great this is for like c-span
me doing all these extra things all
right hey
um
so
100 years ago
all these intellectuals jurists doctors
pharmacists any any armenian older man
who could in some way
create an insurrection against the turks
were arrested and murdered and around
that time the beginning of the vast
killings of armenian christians all over
uh asia minor began and so that's why we
celebrate that date for me it's also
significant because it's my birthday so
it's a odd thing that i'm sort of marked
as an armenian i have this significant
birthday
um
before i go any further
and before i start telling you about
operation nemesis and what they did
i want to read
some
testimony from the armenian genocide
when people were actually being killed
this is testimony from
children who were ended up
growing to be old they were orphaned
during the genocide and when they were
in their 80s they gave testimony
it's it's a very disturbing thing to
watch a video of an old man tell stories
from his childhood and literally be
crying for his mother as he's telling
the story uh the reason that i felt it
was very important to have this sort of
testimony in this book is because we
have to understand what motivated these
men to collaborate and murder these
turkish leaders
there are many collections
i read
vast numbers of books on the on the
genocide and on the history of the
period
but
this particular collection by an
armenian woman named virginia
is
is distinctive i think because
she was just so thorough and she found
people and that the testimony they give
is
very very specific and i think it's in
those specific details that we hear the
truth there have been many accusations
over the years that people are
fabricating
information about the genocide and i
would say that in some cases things do
get passed on from one person to the
next and and start to become
more
mythic than truthful but in this case
these are these are undeniable
a little boy named barbarian
was
seven years old when he was deported
he says
we heard afterwards that together with
17 other armenian young men they had
massacred them by night and had thrown
them under the bridge thus when we were
deported there were no males left in our
family they took away my five aunts in
derzor later they cut off their heads
and paled their heads with their
bayonets to show them to us
and then they threw their corpses in the
euphrates we found only half of the body
of my mother's aunt my mother buried her
in the earth they massacred everyone my
mother wept so much she lost her
eyesight
this is a
somebody named savanda moradian born in
harpert which is where my family is from
in 1905 she was 10 years old at the time
of the deportations 1915.
they confined all the young people in a
cave-like place poured kerosene from an
opening in the roof and set fire to them
then they gathered all the women and
smashed their heads with stones they
killed my mother and grandmother with
stones too they separated the children
like lambs from their mother sheep i had
a three-year-old sister they took her
also together with other children near
the euphrates river bridge cut their
throats and threw them in the river
i think sometimes there's a
misunderstanding that children were
always spared and were then abducted or
taken as uh
um you know slaves or used in
prostitution or whatever but often the
children would just be killed um
megaditch carapachian same name as my
grandfather born in diabetes in 1910
was six years old
they separated us the children and took
the adults towards the valley and made
them stand in a line there were about
three to four hundred adults and we the
children were nearly as many they made
us sit on the green grass and we didn't
know what was going to happen
breaking from the line my mother came
several times to us she kissed and
kissed us and went back we my elder
brother i and my one-year-old brother
saw from afar a line of women moving
forward our mother was among them
on coming out of our house mother was
dressed in her national costume a velvet
dress embroidered in gold thread her
head was adorned with gold coins on her
neck was a gold chain
25 gold coins were secretly sewn inside
her dress on both sides
when mother came for the last time and
kissed us madly i remember she was clad
only in her underwear there were no
ornaments no gold and no velvet clothes
we the children were unaware of the
events happening there
the way uh
the
the ottoman government which was at the
time run by the committee for union in
progress um which was it itself sort of
headed by talat pasha the way they
affected their uh genocide was to first
of all
induct all the young armenian men into
the army there was a war going on
once the men young men were in the army
they were disarmed and they were put
into labor battalions and worked as
slaves until they died
or they would be just taken off to some
remote area and murdered that got rid of
all the young people that got rid of
anybody who might cause a start a
rebellion
the next group were the elite possible
leaders the potential leaders and that
was the sort of arrest that happened in
constantinople on april 24th but
actually kept happening all over the
country wherever there was a town
the turkish soldiers would arrive and
they would find whoever the leaders were
in the town the priests the mayors the
doctors anybody educated they would
arrest them
and they would
take them away
the people in the town didn't always
really know where everybody was going
but they would be taken somewhere and
killed and then finally what was left of
these towns it was a small village and
it was armenian they would simply come
and kill everybody but it was a larger
place they would evacuate the area that
was the armenian section for instance in
ayrshinjin which was the the city that
one of the assassins came from
that city had 25 000 armenians living
there at the time 1915
and
basically everybody was taken away and
either was murdered along the
deportation caravans toward derzor or in
some cases
a speedier killing would occur like they
would throw them off cliffs into the
euphrates river and drown them there
were different methods used all over the
empire
in the major major cities like in
constantinople it wouldn't be as direct
because they knew that western observers
would see what was going on
there's no question there was a crime
committed
and there were trials after the war and
during those trials run by the turks in
1919
it was proven that war crimes had been
committed and a number of turkish
leaders were convicted of war crimes and
sentenced to death that included talat
pasha and verapasha and other major
leaders but they had already left
turkey at that point because they knew
at the end of the war they would be
arrested and so they'd escaped to europe
and this is where
operation nemesis comes in now for a
second i just have to step back and tell
you how i came to learn about operation
nemesis because
oddly this is an amazing and remarkable
story that
uh isn't very well known the part of the
story that i had heard about in which is
in the first part of samantha powers
book a problem from hell
is the story of sogamon tetlerion and
sogamontelarion
according to the story that is usually
told and the story that he told in court
was an engineering student
who had survived one of these
deportation caravans by pretending to be
dead he had escaped the region
he had ended up five years later in
berlin and he was a student the war was
over pretty much and as far as the the
killings that was pretty much over at
that time too
and he's walking down the street one day
and who does he see but talat pasha the
leader of the turkish government at the
time of the genocide
that night he has he has horrible
nightmares and his mother comes to him
who he had seen beheaded he said in
court
and his mother said how can you let this
man live he got his he got his hands on
a pistol he followed talat and he with
one bullet shot him down and tala died
he was then immediately arrested there
was a huge court case that was reported
all around the world
and during the court case he basically
said i yes i killed this man but i had
to kill him because he killed he's
responsible for killing my people and
killing my whole family the court felt
that well they were very sympathetic and
uh as people learned more and more about
the genocide at that time wasn't called
the genocide at that time people were
shocked by the facts they were hearing
and so the court became sympathetic
and because tetlerian had physical
ailments
this notion was presented that he was
basically they didn't have the word ptsd
then but that's what they were saying is
that he was traumatized by the
experience and so he had seen this man
he had a it was oh it was
well he was acquitted he was acquitted
and so he was set free
that is the story of sogamont larian
that is the story of the shooting of
talat pasha and that's the story that
most people know
i thought i would write it in i had
heard this story about 10 years ago i
sort of had my interest in being
an armenian-american
sort of ignited by hanging around adam
mcgoyan when we were making the movie
ararat and also by peter balakian's book
black dog of fate
and i wanted to do something and i
thought this will make a movie this is
an easy movie to do i can imagine
writing this in a couple of months
the first act will be the caravans and
uh this horror show of what was
happening
the second act will be berlin and this
young student who survived seeing talet
and shooting him and the third act will
be the trial of course it's very easy to
see that structure there's only one
problem everything that that tetlarion
said in court was a fabrication he was
not a student he didn't just happen to
see talent pasha walking down the street
in fact so the monte clerion was a
member of a
international assassination squad that
was operating out of massachusetts and
that sent agents all over europe and
succeeded in killing at least six major
turkish leaders from the period of the
ottoman of the armenian genocide well i
was astounded when i found this out this
was reported in a book by a man named
jacques de rosie in the 1980s it was
published in france there is a book in
translation in the united states but
it's it's a kind of a difficult book to
read and i just felt that i had to dig
into this as i drilled down and i
learned more and more
i realized the more i learned the less i
knew i didn't really know anything about
armenians and i didn't really know
anything about turks and i didn't know
anything about the ottoman empire or
even world war one or the russian
revolution or oil politics or all these
things that are tangential to this story
and so
i made it my mission to learn as much as
i could and then try and figure out a
way and this was one of the hardest
things about putting this book together
to present it to the reader in an
entertaining way so that they would be
engaged with the story and want to know
what happened next and that's what this
is what's resulted
let me read you um
one of the other assassins this isn't
even tetlereon
hilarion was a kind of a morose
depressed guy
one of the more romantic of the of the
assassins
uh a man named archevir sheragan was
more of a hot spur he was ready for
action all the time this is his story
he killed the grand vizier in rome
uh
about six months later
sheragan's assassination of saeed haleem
was the most flamboyant of the nemesis
kills after arriving in rome sharagian
befriended a young war widow named maria
who invited him to live with her while
stringing maria along sheragan located
saeed haleem's villa villa at 18 via
bartol bartolomeo gustaccio only a short
train ride from the city center
before i have to say i did the audio
book for this book which was five hours
a day for five days
and
it's one thing to write words it's
another thing to have to pronounce them
i have to say especially armenian names
are not easy but
the former grand vizier had established
for himself the life of an italian
gentleman with an entourage having hired
a full-time italian chef a swiss woman
as a housekeeper a bodyguard tethik asmi
as well as the more bilal a young man
haleem had adopted in turkey who was
always at his side
loitering in the neighborhood renowned
as a lover's lane sheraghian began to
woo a young greek girl who lived nearby
curbing any suspicions as to his
perpetual presence in the neighborhood
he made himself familiar with saeed
haleem's habits and schedule
particularly when he was likely to leave
or return to his villa
like tetlerian
sheraghian was impatient to act but
unlike his fellow avenger he was not
going to wait forever for approval from
higher-ups like tetlerian sheraghian was
plagued by a fear of failure but his
solution was to move forward perhaps
because he had not been a soldier he was
not as obedient to the chain of command
lyrian was a soldier fearing that haleem
might suddenly decide to leave rome
shragian made a decision to act unlike
lyrion who had spent the night before
talat's assassination alone in his room
weeping his sad songs
sheragian went shopping he bought
eye-catching new clothes designed to
create drama and distract observers from
his personal features he found a
wide-brimmed black hat and a large black
overcoat perhaps anticipating a possible
inspection of his corpse by the police
coroner he made sure that everything he
wore was brand new from his underwear
outward the next morning sherayan
cleaned and checked his pistol caught
the train out to saeed haleem's
neighborhood and posted himself outside
the villa helena his neighborhood
girlfriend happened by and before
sherean could avoid it he found himself
engaged in amorous conversation trying
to keep his distance he claimed that his
father was arriving any minute and that
he couldn't stop and talk to her helena
was confused hedon sheraghian told her
that his father was dead also why would
he be meeting his father in this
neighborhood hardly paying any attention
to her sheragan kept a lookout for the
approaching horse-drawn carriage
according to his memoirs having spied
the carriage sharadian stepped away from
helena into the middle of the street and
placed himself directly in its path
in one deft move he raised his hand
forcing the horse to rear then slipped
around to the side stepped up onto the
running board and face to face with the
startled former grand vizier fired once
the bullet caught saeed helene square in
the middle of his forehead killing him
instantly sharadian then turned his gun
on the former grand vizier's bodyguard
tephik osmi and ordered him to throw his
weapon out the window as the startled
horse with the carriage in tow and
sherayan hanging onto its side raced
down the avenue sheragan who was not
only an able assassin but an effusive
narrator describes the moments after the
assassination with the imagery of an
action movie madly racing horses and the
posh's head dangling out of the side of
the carriage
he sees himself in the starring role the
strong wind had caught my coat it was
flying straight up from my back and it
made me look like a huge black bird
that's from the legacy which was
sheragan's
memoir of these events
i feel like i'm kind of
getting kind of professorial here and
luxury and i would rather be talking uh
in response to any questions people have
um
the the important point to just keep in
mind about this group of killers is that
this is 1921 they have almost no way to
communicate with each other other than
using cipher telegrams or letters there
are no telephone calls going back and
forth from the u.s to europe they are
stationed all over europe they are
tracking these turkish leaders and they
succeed in basically removing the almost
the entire
government of the of the ottomans during
the war which is kind of astounding i
think
furthermore they are not trained they
are not secret agents
half these guys are
well one man was a cpa in syracuse new
york another was an insurance salesman
from hartford another was a newspaper
editor in
boston mass
they made the decision that due to the
incredible loss of life in the ottoman
empire of armenians they had to do
something especially a guy like uh ted
larion who did lose his mother
um he basically couldn't live if he
didn't do something and if you look at
the photographs in the book of what he
looks like a couple of years after the
killing because he was acquitted and as
did most of these men most of them were
did not go to jail they ended up old men
in california he looks very peaceful
he came to terms with something in
himself by killing a man he called
the monster
i had to write this book because
it didn't exist
i mean it didn't exist in a way for
people to easily get at this and i just
think that if you're going to talk about
the armenian genocide if you don't talk
about what operation nemesis did you're
just not getting the whole story i think
operation nemesis is important to the
armenian genocide as the story of adolf
eichmann is to the jewish holocaust you
have to know about this it's a
punctuation point and it also explains
some hidden parts of middle eastern
history which i make a point of getting
into with the book
the other thing is a lot of the
information about the armenian genocide
is clouded by
uh very tendentious writing on both
sides and i really had to get into this
and establish the context for the reader
what was the ottoman empire who were the
armenians historically what what was hap
how did this happen what was happening
at this time in fact when i began work
with the historian who i worked closely
with on this arm arkham
uh i told him in the beginning i'm not
sure i'm going to use the word genocide
i'm not sure if that accurately
describes what happened
but
i was very careful about my sources
and
i ended up being absolutely convinced it
isn't that hard to be convinced that
this was a planned
uh centrally planned
attempt to eradicate the armenians in
the who are living in the ottoman empire
everyone's entitled to an opinion but
there is a difference between an opinion
and an informed opinion i spent seven
years making sure that i checked my
facts and triple checked my facts i used
sources that weren't even armenian
american or british because i didn't
always think they were the most secure
sources unfortunately there are a lot of
new bits of information coming in all
the time from archives all over the
world so uh and in the story of ted
lirion and and the operation nemesis
continues to be some one that we need to
learn more about i did do research on
its relationship to british intelligence
and that's in here and i'll just leave
you with one final image which is if you
liked that show downton abbey and you
ever watched that show the tassel that
you're looking at is not downton castle
but high clear castle and that was the
home to a man named aubry herbert that's
where he grew up aubry herbert was the
last westerner to talk to talat pasha he
came over to germany to talk to talat
as uh for british intelligence and
talent was dead three weeks later and
the rest of that story is in here as
well but there was a lot of spycraft
going on at the time that intersects
with what the nemesis group was doing
at any rate um
that's my presentation of the book for
now and if you have any questions i'm
happy to answer them
for the microphone
obviously you did a lot of research on
genocide you probably talked to read
about other genocide spent seven years
doing this i wonder if you have any
thoughts about genocide in general you
know we see that now the the murders of
christians and throughout the jews
throughout the you know the arab lands
we recently saw rwanda saw the genocide
of cambodia of course the
jewish genocide you know i wonder if you
have any thoughts on genocide in general
and and
along with that question you never
mentioned the religious uh was there any
religious influence of the young muslim
versus christian in this whole it was
that one of the uh variables that went
into this genocide well you know those
two questions are connected to each
other for me in the way i think about
genocide because first of all
genocide
it's hard for genocide to just
erupt on its own there are usually
leaders who have
uh will benefit from what happens that's
hap that's the case in darfur that was
the case in serbia that was the case in
the united states when we wiped out the
in plains indians there was a benefit
that somebody would get from removing
sometimes indigenous people from an area
as in the case of the herrero people or
the case of the armenians someone sees a
benefit and a decision is made so we
look at it i look at it from the
position of a political decision from a
party and in this way and i talk about
this in the book this uh genocide is
directly related to the jewish holocaust
for no other reason that there were
hundreds of german soldiers in turkey
during world war one who later became ss
officers in world war ii
so
we can we see these connections made and
hitler said who remembers the armenians
in other words something happens and
look there's no punishment nothing
there's no big retribution so the the
with impunity these leaders feel oh i
can get away with this and i i
personally believe i mean
genocide is not my central issue with
this book it's more about let's talk
about this amazing
um
this conspiracy but i do think that
genocide is the opposite of civilization
i can't think of anything more up in
opposition to what civilized people
should be doing when you ask about
religion
in the in the same vein
leaders political leaders will
understand that there's tension between
religious groups and they will foster
that tension encourage it and as in the
case of this situation they will
get the religious leaders to
to instruct people that this is a
religious thing even though it really
isn't
this was this was actually an attempt by
political people to do something called
turkifying they were going to turkify
the ottoman empire make everybody a turk
and and somehow that was going to solve
some major problem they had they felt
with the armenians and other christians
there but it wasn't the people the
religious groups however
unbalanced whatever the stasis was that
they had achieved between themselves
were not always at each other's throats
if they were it wasn't for religious
reasons but for for other reasons just
over land property it's usually why it's
not i mean that's always the case so um
in this instance i mean one thing you
can look at is that the leaders the
young turk leaders themselves or the cup
they weren't particularly religious
themselves
it just wasn't the way they rolled they
were modernists actually and they wanted
to
modernize their country which is a
chilling thought the way they went about
doing it i hope that's an answer hi
thank you
thank you for writing the book
uh your situation was very different
in that your grandfather talked to your
body most uh first generation survivors
didn't
and you're a third generation survivor
so so my question is you think it's
possible in your adolescence and young
adult life you really as you said in
your introduction you weren't that
involved in the armenian community or
young kid enjoying suburban
massachusetts although not far in
watertown cambridge and somerville was a
hotbed of
all kinds of political armenian
political unrest so you think it's
possible
that your grandfather's trauma you might
have inherited it
and this was your way of dealing with it
by writing the book
so can you please comment on that that
you possibly inherited you didn't kill
turks but you inherited his his pain and
his loss and you dealt with it by this
book okay
you're going to make a movie
am i going to make a movie movie we'll
wait on the movie for a bit i
i think there is a movie here because of
the the amazing fact that these these
very humble men pulled this off i think
that's the movie for sure it's not like
an action movie it's more about
i mean the notion of a cpa in syracuse
helping to run the money which speaking
of that cpa his name was aaron aaron uh
sachoclian and his granddaughter just
published a book called sacred justice
in which she publishes some of the
letters that were passed between these
conspirators and she talks about
intergenerational trauma a great deal in
that book
uh
i have no doubt that um
when these when this kind of intense
stuff happens that it will be passed on
and i believe that it has been passed on
to me in some way but i don't think that
working on this book or exploring my
roots is so much about some kind of
therapy for myself but rather an
understanding that my whole life and i
am 62 on friday my whole life is equal
in value all the way along the line so
when i was 40 i thought i'm a guy that
writes plays i'm a guy that's been on in
a movie or something that's who you
asked me who i am that's who i am but
today i think to myself i'm a guy who
writes plays i'm a guy who's in a movie
and i'm a guy that stood next to my
grandfather at seven years old and
watched him make shish kebab and that
guy is just as important as this other
guy it's all one big thing i think
that's natural for
when you get older to look back at your
roots and say
what am i made of and not deny that
these people who were your people when
you were young in my case
you know they were
from another country they spoke in
accents they were
they were the other and here i was like
you say i was a suburban kid riding
around on my bike or smoking dope at the
mall or something and i'm that's where
my head is at i'm not thinking of myself
as a
armenian meaning exotic person i'm
thinking of myself as an american
and but i am an armenian i mean for me
to deny
all of that that came into me as a very
young person and i was an altar boy so
it wasn't like i was that far off the
uh
out of the army i mean i was was a
church sunday school every weekend and
and i was imbued with this so i just i
think it is it's a part of owning it all
and this whole process i mean one of the
things about this book is that i mean
i've worked on a lot of projects over
the years and i've spent more time on
this book than any other project that
i've ever worked on and i i think that
kind of speaks to
just how it drew me the gravitational
pull
i'm not a historian i'm not a scholar
and i think maybe for that reason it was
always fresh for me all along the line i
was incredibly excited by the process it
maybe it was the detective in me from
law and order that i
wanted to find out what was going to
happen next but i uh
that it was i was out at the university
of michigan for a couple of months in
the fall and
they their stacks are open at this
graduate library and i was
i was in bliss to want to be able to get
my hands on all this information
it's a side of me hi
microphone microphone sir they need to
hear you got to visit uh and how many
times say any of these uh indigenous
places that you that are referenced so
much in the book i traveled a bit i did
i could have traveled more i've first of
all i've been to armenia which i would
recommend to anybody who is of armenian
heritage it's an amazing place what's
left of it up in the mountains the tiny
republic of armenia
i've been to turkey a couple of times
turkey's a very beautiful country
it's a bittersweet experience for an
armenian especially a turkish armenian
which is what i hail from to be there
um
i mean i can feel it when i'm there that
this was where i came from
and yet when you
hear the call to prayer from the mosques
i mean i personally can't help but
wonder where these are the last things
my great grandfathers heard before their
i can't even imagine what happened to
them
um
i went to berlin to look to investigate
where uh talat was assassinated i've
been to rome i've been to that
neighborhood many times anyway i even
went to glendale to interview
silva manoogian who is the daughter of
shahan natalie who was pretty much the
ringleader on the ground he he kept
everything moving
um
but yeah i
i did it in a in a kind of like i don't
have this now now i have to go get this
i don't know about this where is this i
have to go find this so if i would
discover that there might be something
having to do with spy circles that i
didn't have i didn't know about
i would get in touch with friends in
london see if there was a graduate
student who could jump into the british
archives for me and look up what was
aubrey herbert talking about with
you know this guy on march 16th i mean
some of those things are
so amazing i would love to just keep
doing them for years and years and years
but i had to finish the book eventually
for example aubry herbert claims that he
he never said that he really had
anything to do with the assassination
aubry herbert kept a fastidious journal
every day of his life the only day that
he doesn't have a journal entry is the
day after talat is assassinated he has
just met with talat two weeks before
he's a member of this circle of spies in
great britain the next day he writes i
read in the newspaper that talat pasha
was assassinated that's really sad and
you think
you read in the newspaper
really
okay
so these are the circumstantial stuff it
was it was very interesting i try and
share some of that in the book
hi yes
lady yes you don't keep looking by and
do it too
do i mention the assyrians um
i do mention them in the book i don't
focus on them as much but i i will
mention in various places
that
especially in the regions that are
roughly north of where isis is operating
now
the nestorians chaldeans these people
were also
you know taken out
villages were destroyed people there was
a
genocide against them as well
it's complicated because when you talk
about a nationality specifically when
you talk about the armenians you're
talking about people that actually break
into different groups there were really
sophisticated and politically savvy
armenians in
constantinople a guy like armen garrow
who was the ring the the executive
director of this conspiracy he didn't
see himself as anything but completely
equal to talat pasha he didn't see
himself as subordinate he would go and
tell him what he thought he was a they
had a constitutional government at that
time he was in parliament he felt he had
every right to say whatever he wanted to
say
as opposed to the serfs who were in the
very very far eastern regions which is
where these um
syriac christians were living and those
people like the jews and the shtetls in
during world war ii they didn't know
what hit them
i mean these people were just leaving
living these humble lives
far away from anything sophisticated
there weren't even railroad lines
through those areas
yeah and the same thing is happening
right now yes it's it's unbelievably
tragic
when you talk about the syriac people uh
it was only been recently that certain
scholars discovered that
that villages that they thought were
armenian were actually syriac um and
these are the oldest christians in the
world and they speak aramaic and it's
it's it's it's it's so unjust it's it's
mind-blowing and they just roll in and
they kill everybody
um very very harsh yes
hi
[Music]
good
the last question sort of anticipated my
own but i'm going to ask it anyway uh
forgive me that the name escapes me at
the moment but there's a
a place in northern syria which is
called the armenian auschwitz
where
thousands of people were marched there
um and uh rounded up in camps and uh
either massacred or starved to death
um
and uh
yeah
derezor thank you thank you and as i'm
sure you're aware it was recently taken
by isis and the shrine which had been
built there in the memorial museum were
destroyed
so first i'm wondering if you
touch on this place in your book and the
more general question is
once again it appears in very much the
same part of the world
uh you know you've got um christians and
yazidis and other minorities being
targeted for extermination by isis and
not very much is done about it so i
wonder if you
um you know share my sense of despair
that um
cycle just seems to be doomed to
keep repeating itself well my my my own
politics uh and my beliefs about paul
sort of extend beyond
some of these issues to to sort of
overall
issues i'm a pacifist i am not a
nationalist i am very anti
landmine anti
uh the
this dispersal of automatic weapons all
over the middle east i think there can
be ways where we can put pressure on the
manufacturers and the arms trade and so
forth and i think we need to look
specifically at the middle east and look
at oil and talk about how does oil make
all of this move forward
um as far as derzor
yeah i mean it's it's it's
uncanny how
isis is moving right along the same
track as the this what they call the
special organization which were the
were these terror groups that were uh
genus committing genocide to these poor
armenians uh and yes the in fact i was
just sharing an evening with robert fisk
uh just a couple of nights ago in
detroit and he had visited that shrine
for the armenians in der zor and in that
shrine are bones that have been
collected out of the desert of the
people that's all they can just find the
bones and they bring them there and isis
arrived and threw all the bones out into
the streets and burned the place down so
um
yeah it's i think there's an overall
i mean again this is a such a much
bigger topic about the politics of the
middle east
but if i despair about anything it's the
fact that the middle east becomes more
and more homogenized whether it's
countries become all muslim or they
become all any religion
it's it's horrible because
um i'm a lover of humanity and these
great cities like smyrna salonika
constantinople uh alexandria all these
places where places where people of all
different faiths and all different
backgrounds
blended together and traded with one
another and created these amazing
cultures they're all part of one much
larger culture and sadly it gets pulled
into these pieces and of course it's not
just christian
muslim it can be sunni shia it's goes on
and on
um and that's maybe a topic for another
day
well i wrote the book because like i
said it this was so remarkable
i just felt i had to write about it
because i thought people needed to know
about it i do things because
i don't know
they interest me and that's what pulls
me toward them and so that's what
happened in this case and i wasn't
disappointed
um
did you say that that was that lady back
there yeah you hi
yes
oh you need the mic
they want to hear you and they wanted to
be on the c-span
thing
thank you for going through the history
of this we often hear
that this happened under autumn and
turkey but as you've pointed out the
committee for union in progress
as far as i can understand the timeline
was a part of modern turkey and
nationalist ideology certification i'm
wondering if you could speak to that a
little bit and also as a public figure
i'm wondering if you have received any
pressure over this because so many
others have
uh as a public figure and and getting
any kind of pressure i have not gotten
any pressure i mean today when i was on
leonard lopate show people were calling
in who were making accusations about me
being racist or something and
uh i actually i think those points are
well taken i think we need to be
objective when we're talking about
people who
come from a different tradition than the
western tradition and i think the turks
have suffered from that that bias
against them in the case of
c.u.p and whether it was part of the
ottoman empire it was part of the otter
the ottoman empire ended
and at the end of world war one
and at the beginning of the republic of
turkey so you you have a period of like
a year where it's kind of a gray area
but
the republic of turkey began 1923 1922
1923 under uh kamal ataturk and the
committee for union in progress was the
last
group of leaders
in the ottoman empire there was still a
sultan to the very end he just didn't
have any power there was still a grand
vizier to the very end this man said
pasha who um i um
i just described his assassination he
was the grand vizier but
the
the uh
part of the young turks that was known
as the cup were they kind of had him as
a figurehead grand vizier to rubber
stamp the deportations and so forth
it's a
there are political
parties and movements that are illegal
and that is what the the cup at this
point is from about
it's last year before world war one it's
an illegal organization from about 1913
on they are assassinating people and
they are taking power by
by muscle as opposed to
democratically and that's this that you
can see that same thing happening in you
know under hitler in germany it's
it's a
constitution constitutional way to take
over a country and that's what happened
in this case and talat was definitely
the strong man in that case until
until he was assassinated
hi
one more
this is the one more
thanks for writing this book thank you
meaningful um so uh your point of view
on a couple of
points that i'm i want to bring to your
attention obviously the events at the
vatican this past weekend
bringing together the two catholics of
the armenian church which in itself was
pretty much of a miracle yes uh and the
term
genocide used by the pope
uh and by the two armenian popes
uh and
that in relation to every single
president u.s president presidential
candidate
i guess going back to jimmy carter
that's as far back as i can remember
probably longer than that uh promising
in their candidacy that they will
recognize the armenian
genocide
and then of course nothing happens
why
does not the world why doesn't the world
community finally just say
listen
we'll never get turkey to
admit to this because of oil because of
strategic
relationships et cetera et cetera you're
you're so you're answering the question
as you're asking it that's what's
happening here
yeah turkey is strategic and uh the old
uh
question where does a three thousand
pound gorilla sleep anywhere he wants to
turkey denies this because they can they
don't
feel like admitting to this uh they have
a very very powerful forget the lobby
outside turkey within turkey they've
created structures that generation after
generation teach people that the
armenians were
bad people
and that this never happened they also
have other theories that for instance
there were never any armenians in turkey
to begin with so it's kind of hard to
put them all together into one theory
but for example if you go to turkey
every there are 50 museums 50
in turkey called turkish archaeological
museums
and these museums are meant to tell you
about the history of the region going
back thousands of years there is no
mention of armenians anywhere in any of
these museums
likewise you can go as i did to the
military museum in istanbul and you will
find the hall that is basically sort of
titled the truth about the armenians and
then it will just catalog all these
atrocities that armenians committed
against turks and they'll keep pushing
with this notion that it's the armenians
who did the bad things to the turks
the truth is is that there were
armenians who were
working against the ottoman empire
during world war one and even prior but
that's not an excuse for
evacuating an entire civilian population
and killing them that's just means that
there are those people there and you
have to deal with them
they numbered in the thousands as
opposed to the over millions that were
murdered
so
that's that's the situation in turkey
turkey spends a lot of time and money on
convincing the world that well they've
learned they've learned from the tobacco
lobby and they've learned from the
anti-global warming lobby that you don't
really have to argue against it you just
have to sow seeds of doubt and so they
say there's a debate
and uh hillary clinton said it recently
that it's a debate it's a historical i
don't know what the debate is it would
be like debating whether world war one
ever happened or whether the holocaust
ever happened i mean these aren't real
debates they're not historical debates
but if you grow up in turkey it's
possible that you can grow up and
actually never hear
the truth no textbooks are going to tell
the truth what happens is you end up
with very
strange things where because turkey is a
modern country people work their way up
into graduate school they become
historians for example muge gochek who
is now one of the main
turkish writers on the armenian genocide
and she comes to princeton to work
and somebody to ask says to her an
armenian guy says why did your
grandfather kill my grandfather and she
said i have no idea what you're talking
about she had never heard she had no
idea and that and this was her major and
so then she began to study it in fact i
would recommend anybody who has any
doubts just read the turkish writers who
are doing the the cutting edge word
tanner akhtam or muge
and you will it i mean the research is
stunning
uh so this is where we're at today
and i believe that it will turn but
slowly it's not going to happen this
year
and the turkish people have to write
their own history we can't write their
history for them
i would
point out to any american
that the united states made a decision
to wipe out the plains indians after the
civil war and were pretty good at it
that was approximately around 1870 and
it was around 1970 that bury my heart at
wounded knee came out and americans
started to you know in a large fashion
say oh wait a minute these native
americans weren't horrible people they
weren't as i saw when i was a little kid
watching cowboys and indians movies they
were you know horribly scalping us these
things were happening is true
but we had done this horrible thing to
these people to clear those lands
it's about a hundred years later
we're now at a hundred years after the
genocide and i'm hoping that very soon
and many many turks understand this this
this understanding will just evolve and
hopefully move to the next stage what
the government of turkey does you know
what those guys are going to be gone in
five years and then there will be a
possibility for people to finally it
would be good for the turks
it's not just a matter of what's good
for armenians or anybody else the people
of the region need to get this past them
and i think that's one of the reasons
why the pope spoke out because the pope
and
just the other day the new york times
realized that
this isis thing grows out of this
confused way of looking at the issues
and we have to be clear and we have to
understand what civilization is
and this is not civilization we have to
stand up for what's right
um i think that's all we've got thank
you
so we have one more round of applause
for eric
[Applause]
if you'd like to have your book signed
please stay seated give us one moment to
prepare the stage we'll call you up row
by row if you would like to purchase
operation nemesis you can do so over at
the fourth floor register
thank you for coming
every weekend book tv offers programming
focused on